come this way great I'm gonna have you
just turn around and don't take that
blindfold off but just stay there for
with me for one second don't take it off
okay this is the most exciting
blindfolded experience I've ever had
Shades yeah you do all right Drew um I
have this right here you guys all right
so uh Drew I'm gonna have you remove the
blindfold right now the chains really
foreign
so Drew you are of course in a glass
cage because we know that you love a
certain show
so we brought you to you and
come on out you
know
it's not supposed to be this way it's
not supposed to be this way here here
here here this is this is a birthday
gift for you I know that you like to
remove stains
you're not supposed to want this
[Laughter]
[Music]